so anthony trelope he was a writer
who published 47 novels 18 works of
nonfiction
12 short stories two plays
and a series of um articles and letters
he wrote in 15 minute intervals for
three hours
every single day he would write 250
words
every 15 minutes and after he was done
that he would take a little break
as sad as this may sound we are all
results driven creatures
and personally i love just
checking off that little box off of my
task list let's say i'm writing an essay
and it takes days or weeks and on my
task list
i just have write an essay for a really
long time i'm not going to
be able to get that satisfaction of
completing a task
at the end of the day honestly i'm not
going to feel that accomplished because
i didn't check off anything on my to-do
list
in that case i would just break it up
into smaller tasks you know i would
say okay you're gonna write 200 words
and i would give myself a time limit and
then just pump out those 200 words
whether it's good or bad just do it
and then later on you can give yourself
a task to review that work
and edit it when you complete smaller
tasks it builds momentum
and it adds fuel for for the long run
also when you complete a meaningful task
quickly it energizes you
and it motivates you to do more tasks
quickly and so i would challenge you
to try to schedule your most important
tasks right in the morning
and obviously break it up into little
chunks that's manageable so that you can
do it within the time that you have in
the morning
but i think it'll really help you build
confidence
and energize you for the rest of the day
because it definitely works for me
you